to address the first point how do we
just resolve kind of a discreet
agreement in general I would say it so
if it's kind of a small disagreement
then maybe we can work it through with
just some quick conversation it might be
just like one person clarifying what
they mean and then we'll both agree and
then that's a that's easy to resolve for
bigger issues I say something Alex and I
have pretty strong opinions about
certain things for the really big issues
where we both have different opinions at
that point we both know that in order to
resolve this we like each of us need to
present enough justification and
reasoning so that so we're both trying
to persuade each other with evidence and
data and then usually at the end of that
we come up with a reasonable compromise
trains more of the data in an evidence
person I would more most of my
disagreements often stem from an
intuition standpoint so it's a little
harder for me to always justify in the
moment why I think I'm right so
oftentimes what I'll do is I'll either
do other research or I'll bring in a
professor or or a technical staff or
someone who knows a little bit more